hey everyone diavolo here and on my Lord
we are finally back for some more of the
absolutely god tier series that is
tatsuki fujimoto's chainsaw man but this
time it's slightly differently as now we
are moving forward into the new and
currently releasing part two of the
series so if you are new around here and
want to watch more of my manga
narrations and explain stuff for a
variety of different series then make
sure you hit that subscribe button and
also be sure to leave a like on the
video as it really helps out with
pushing my stuff to a bunch of new
amazing people but of course enough of
that sit back and relax as we dive into
the extremely Twisted world of tatsuki
Fujimoto so just before we do start off
though if you all don't know big
Fujimoto decided to completely switch
things up with this story and seemingly
to start with we forget about our number
one chainsaw man dingy and his story to
save power along with looking after the
new controlled evil to instead solely
focus on this new but damn amazing
character called ASA mitaka anyways as
slings kick off and hit like odd
chainsaw man way who teach her Mr Tanaka
brings in and introduces a chicken devil
named Bucky to the class as him weirdly
explained to them that in three months
the class will harvest and eat Bucky in
order to give them an understanding of
exactly how precious life is instantly
Bucky becomes some sort of mascot for
the students as everyone rolls up
wanting to touch him except for mitaka
who's instead annoyed that the creepy
thing is sitting on her desk because of
this she leaves the classroom already
wanting the devil to die and Retreats up
to the school roof to eat her lunch
alone as she stands paved off at the
railing mitaka is joined and interrupted
by the student council president gotta
love those Japanese shows how there's
always some kind of like student council
leader involved in this story and almost
every single Japanese school somehow it
just must be a thing over there and it's
quite like odd being from New Zealand
and never having had that Dynamic before
I just think it's quite funny anyways
esmitaka ends up going on an annoyed
ramble about how this city is corrupt
and made up of illegally constructed
buildings she points out that there is
even a chainsaw devil running around
playing devil Hunter which is obviously
our melon loving boy of course and to
make it even all worse now there is a
freaking chicken devil in their class
room standing there she wishes that both
of them would just hurry up and die as
time begins to fly by misaki observes an
annoyance how attached to classmates
become to the chicken devil finally
after three months the Day of Reckoning
is upon her though yet as utaka sits
there she's utterly flabbergasted to see
her whole class stand up in defiance
over them having to take the chicken
Devil's life then on top of that to blow
her away like even more it's even
revealed that this was the entire plan
behind the genius that is Mr Tanaka he
states that he didn't want them to take
life lightly even if it was a devil's
then on some absolutely top tier teacher
Vibe he invites the entire classroom out
for a game of soccer to celebrate
Bucky's pardoning after sitting in the
class for a moment alone mitaka ends up
following them outside but reluctantly
stays off to the side watching his
students play instead of joining them
being approached by her friend Tanaka
asks why she's all by herself and not
joining in to which she replies that she
goes to school to study not to make
friends yet absolutely out of nowhere
Bucky suddenly run and jumps into her
arms and tells her it's time to come out
of her shell standing there and seeing
everyone around her mitaka is suddenly
taken aback by her classmates
heartwarming invitation to join them and
in that moment she realizes that she's
actually hated everyone in school
because she was just jealous of them
having been inspired by big Bucky she
decides to finally join her class but
when she runs over she suddenly trips
and falls onto her stomach man like I
absolutely love the way Fujimoto goes
around isolating certain characters
especially with the like the new
characters you've only just met but
anyways anyways as mintaka fearfully
gets back up she looks down at her lap
in horror as she discovers that she has
accidentally crushed Bucky underneath
her completely unlife in him after
everyone's horrified screams bit an
image into mitaka's mind she returns
home completely ashamed and going over
the craziest hypotheticals in her own
mind mitaka does end up going to school
the next day but only feels her
classmates steers judging her back at
home again She lays away sulking over
how she just wants to die until suddenly
she hears her doorbell rang suspiciously
outside it's revealed that the class
president and her teacher Mr Tanaka have
come to walk her to Bucky's grave as
they think by his Spirit might forgive
her and she'll feel better on the way
there Tanaka and the class president
cross the street but mutaka holds back
due to the red lights the class
president instantly like gets annoyed
and realizes what she's up to and begins
to Beret her for it calling her I could
eat toe shoes they're completely out of
nowhere she starts going on some like
evil villainous Tyrant about how Mr
Tanaka told her to be friends with
mitaka before suddenly mutating into a
multi-headed Colossus made up of muscles
it's revealed that she has made a
contract with a Justice devil before
then also doing like the craziest thing
like bro you're a high schooler and
claiming that Mr Tanaka had been having
relations with her but because the
teacher was a freaking freak he had a
thing from itaka which had held him back
from going further in their own
relationship because of this the class
prayers thinks that the only way for
them to be happy is to kill mitaka then
into mini marking my level control the
Justice level reveals that it was also
her plan for mutaka to kill Bucky in
order to humiliate her in front of
everyone the transformed class president
then lunges at mitaka with a claws going
to finish her off and Azul last second
passes she weirdly feels at PACE knowing
that it wasn't her fault at all for
killing Bucky no instead the class
president was just jealous of her and
their perhaps if she had lived a more
selfish life she could have added better
life or even perhaps a boyfriend her
face is then sadly clawed open by the
class president and she's left to die on
the ground Underneath Him Now green
lights which is like holy man this is
like a one second long fight here or
something around there all this crazy
ass class Prince had to do was just like
chill out for two seconds and literally
be a good two shoes and cross the road
anyways it happens for a reason because
in that moment and out of nowhere a
devil with similar eye to that of mahima
which has taken the form of an owl
randomly appears on that freaking green
light looking down it tells me Tarka
that if she wants to live her body will
belong to words her body then suddenly
reanimates itself standing up complete
healed before she can even answer
instantly she grabs good old Mr Tanaka
and turns him into this extremely raw
looking long sword with spikes
protruding from the back and an obvious
kink in the middle as they scream in
fear wondering what the hell she just
turned into mitaka states that her name
is the war devil and it's time for a
warm-up pill as the priest swings at her
the war devil effortlessly uses her
teacher's sword to cut off the Justice
Devil's arm then instantly morphs it
into a grenade showing of her ability to
turn objects into weapons of war she
then in a matter of milliseconds Cuts
clean through the Justice devil and
implants the teacher sword inside of the
monster before quickly lobbing the
grenade at the two leading the creepy
lovebirds together for the final moments
as the war differ like a complete and
other badass like this has to be some
kind of movie reference as well from
tatsuki here as walking away from the
explosion she sees a party poster on the
wall where the chainsaw man's face on
Earth looking at it she tells him to
wait before vowing to find him and make
him vomit back up nuclear weapons by the
way guys the reason that she has the
same eyes is mahima as due to the war
devil being a part of the Four Horsemen
out of these four horsemen here the one
that we have seen as the first Horseman
known as the plague or pestilence but
it's like also known as or interpreted
as conquest or control or domination So
that obviously means milky mummy makima
also known as like obviously the
controlled evil who came first followed
by next which is like the war devil and
that's like what we're in right now with
our new girl mataka here the war devil
then famine which be extremely
interesting and finally death who I'm
assuming is the strongest of the four
and I'm guessing that this might be the
course that tatsuki is currently taking
with like his Series in general so we
might have four long paths to a series
that'll be quite cool anyway skipping
forward to the next day now mitaka wakes
up in beard and lays there pondering the
previous day's events she turns to her
side to find herself literally just
chilling there opposite her but instead
of a normal beautiful self she has scars
on her face and those spiral eyes I was
just talking about lying there the war
devil reveals this isn't a dream this is
her reality so hurry up and get ready
for school
she shows these shocked mitaka the new
teacher and class president did indeed
die and it was really them who killed
them not wanting to hear it though itaka
snaps back at her saying that it wasn't
her that killed them but actually this
random devil that showed up she tries to
push through her devil devil yet after a
moment the award evil reveals that she
can't touch her as your brain has just
seen her as a hallucination it's
explained that yesterday mitaka did
indeed die but the ward evil had claimed
her body confused on how she's even able
to move then at this point War says that
she kept half of her brain attacked as
she is unfamiliar with human society and
needs help in locating the chainsaw man
she reveals from her pocket a button
that matches metaka's school uniform and
explains that it was supposedly found in
the remnants of a devil the chainsaw man
defeated which means that he must be
going to his school in hiding after
arriving at the school ASA immediately
starts to have second thoughts about
going though having seen this war
threatens her once more but even still
Mitaki can't bring herself to go to
school she begins to start having a
panic attack literally stating that
she'd rather die than go go when
suddenly the handsome lug like
everyone's favorite devil Hunter toon
school student our boy big Yoshida asks
if she's okay instantly the wardy will
tells her to ask the boy if he knows
where the chainsaw man is but she
refuses telling her to just shut up for
a second anointed minion isn't even
listening to her though the war devil
suddenly enters mataka's body taking
control of her motive functions and
pulling Assa from her own body he wore
default thing users mitaka's Mika
skeleton to ask this boy where the
chainsaw man is he says that he heard a
rumor but also explains to her that he
actually just transferred here so he
doesn't really know too much what he
does know though is that the rumor was
that he joined the devil Hunters Club I
found this super like funny with uh
asahir and Hal in a way it's kind of
like sukuna or being inside of yuji's
body except like a polar opposite with
the female version here of like having
like this war Devil Type level of like
being being stuck inside of your body
and telling you what to do and trying to
control you while you're like nah bro I
don't want this to be happening but
anyway anyway satisfied with this new
information the war devil literally
pulls on your Shader he didn't inhaler
close and calling him boy before asking
if she shall make him her boyfriend but
yeshida being the man with the world's
best foresight declines her offer and
simply walks away blown up in an
emotionless devil mitaka asks her why in
the world she would even do that twitch
is revealed and we actually find out the
power of the war devil extremely early
on especially like in comparison to say
denji's part and what she didn't happen
until like the control devil she says
that she has the ability to turn what's
hers into weapons so say if someone were
to fall in love with her like Yoshida
then she could easily turn him into a
weapon of hers she states that she wants
to turn as many humans as possible into
weapons and go to war with the chainsaw
man standing there and now back in her
body mitaka is horrified at this
situation she's found herself in she
realizes that surely this wardiffle must
be bad news as this scarier a devil's
name is the stronger it is as she thinks
that she needs to get in contact with a
devil Hunter before she loses full
control of your body War cuts her off
and tells her to not spill the beams as
if he tells anyone at about a devil
taking over her body she's dead shaking
with fear War explains to metaka that
she can't even hide her thoughts from
her as they are technically one now but
instead of arguing over what to do
proposes that if they can beat the
chainsaw man together she'll in return
give her body back to her after mitaka
agrees to cooperate with the devil she
forces herself to go to these schools
devil Hunter Club while all of the
Mindless students roll in a dude that
I'm guessing is probably a club leader
screams out that they will be all sorted
into teams of three to help Patrol the
city for devils and that they only have
one week to bring back a real dared
devil failure to do so means that
they'll be kicked out of the club there
we also find that our girl is paired
with two other students one of which
just happens to be the boy she met in
front of the school that morning
skipping out on their little Mission ASA
Yoshida and the girl with glasses walk
down the halls of the school hunting for
Devils the girl with glasses asks if
it's really possible for Devils to be
hiding inside of the school to what
sushida says that because it's the
biggest school inside of Tokyo some
devils do supposedly live and unused
classrooms to make small talk along the
way and break the odd atmosphere the
girl on the glasses introduces herself
as Yuko someone who's recently gotten
into chainsaw man she asks if the others
like him as well tuition finally
introduces himself to the girls and says
that he's also a big fan he asks USA
she's also into him but a new typical
picture fights day she can only mutter
her name and respond before claiming
that she is also a big fan of him like
most other people mitaka who is like
visibly uncomfortable and desperately
not wanting to be in the situation then
notices three absolute hoes from her
class in front of her as all of them
pass her by they start giggling and even
commenting on the nerve that she has
trying to get a boyfriend after what she
did to Bucky obviously the Romans have
probably gone around the school that she
must have asked out the new dude big
Yoshida on a date or just to be her
boyfriend or something like that but
anyways anyways as USA grows more
uncomfortable and awkwardly goes to
leave US state that there's something
she's got to do as an excuse to get away
while leaving the school she shoots over
to her locker room to grab her shoes but
once opening it mitaka sadly comes to
the realization there's someone from her
class stuffed raw chicken into a locker
completely ruining her skull shoes
having followed up and caught up with
Asa yuku tries asking her what's wrong
yeah because mitaka is completely
disheartened and wants to just leave now
she says she's fine which is obviously
just another excuse and goes to leave
having walked down these School steps
and heading for the gate in her socks
now the war devil stands there saying
that it's only going to hurt their feet
as she walks home like this mitaka
though just ignores who countless
Rambles and says she's fine once more
but before she can continue Yoko like
the topaz babe she is cuts her off
saying now that can't be true turning
around mitaka notices that Yoko was
holding his shoes in her hands now and
only wearing her socks as well she then
offers her one of her own shoes so that
only one foot would hurt which is like
good old tatsuki with this like
completely not a Randomness but anyways
as awkwardly tries to say that she's
fine once again but yuku doesn't even
listen instead running off and telling
me tell to give her other shoot back to
her after the two of them ran through
the streets absolutely messing up their
socks they end up back at yuko's house
yuku invites user in but once again she
instantly declines any form of
friendship keep him with her cheery
attitude though Yuko sees user off and
Sistine that she have both of his shoes
this time and if she doesn't want them
then she can just throw them away or
sell them man I I absolutely love the
war devil and how completely out of
touch she is here as our extremely
depressed and confuse us walked home the
war devil actually asks her if they're
going to sell those shoes to watch
mutaka asks if she's a complete idiot
now moving forward to the next day as
school starts out it turns out beg
Yoshida had actually skipped school and
probably gone like macca's or he's out
on a mission or something for the bureau
because of this yaku and ASA walk ahead
to the city together to hunt some devils
while discussing things about their
lives along the way they reveal to each
other that both of their parents were
killed by Devils which excites Yuko and
makes his Spurs hell that they're just
like the main characters from a manga
due to all the excitement Yoko says that
she has to leave for the bathroom and
goes to shoot off while in her absence
the war devil reappears on the bench
sitting next to ASA and telling her that
they should kill her new friend as then
explained to her that the guilty issue
feels about creating a weapon the more
powerful it will be War tells USA to
quickly find a building with little to
no risk of being caught so she can kill
Yoko however ASA refuses screaming back
at her and probably looking mentally
insane as she sits there alone telling
her hallucination to quit calling her
girl she insists that the war devil
colored by her own name and in return
the war devil who's just trying to
straight up be a nuisance at this point
finally reveals her own name as well
which is like yes I can I can actually
finally stop calling a war as it just
didn't feel right it was kind of like
weird and cringy in a way she tells me
taka takulu yoru and decides to drop his
subject for now as the closest she gets
to Yuko the stronger the weapon she'll
end up becoming after yuku ends up
returning the two of them wander around
the city with mitaka realizing he's
having so much fun she literally
couldn't care about a thing in the world
as they attempt to locate a devil a
politician on this street nearby barks
to a group of 20 bystanders that what is
truly the leading cause of death for
Japanese citizens he explains that out
of the 20 people in front of him five
will die of illness five will die of old
age one in a traffic accident two from
unlifing of differing degrees and
finally the remaining Stephen will all
be killed by Devils he screams even
louder replacing himself to the point
that he can still be heard even by Yuko
and mitaka as they roll up on a familiar
devilish face standing in front of the
girls the new bat devil who seems like
way more bulked up than last time begins
tearing apart a random civilian by the
way if you if you're confused about how
the hell the bat devil is even back in
the world all of a sudden it's pretty
much like most likely that he would have
revived in the human world after having
been killed again inside of Hell which
is where all the devils live as per the
life cycle of devils apart from those
that are obviously swallowed up by dingy
as those utterly erased from existence
but anyways that's as much as we know so
far Frozen a new place still as I say
it's the devil standing in front of her
beautiful appears and warns her that
this is some extremely bad news it's
explained that in their current state
there is no possible way they could
defeat the Devil and on top of that Yoda
wasn't able to take over Us's body when
she's struck him with fear she tries to
get her to back away safely so the devil
doesn't notice them yet both of the
girls who are obviously panicked quickly
turn and run for their lives with a new
bat devil chasing attacking and Diving
after the girls who are desperately
trying to escape it causes the entire
building to begin collapsing under his
enormous size coming too after being
almost knocked out mitaka sees her new
friend has been incapacitated with a
pike running through her ankle as the
bat devil munches down on another random
civilian yoru orders ASA to use this
moment to kill her friend once again so
that they can turn her into a weapon she
even tries gaslighting her into it by
implying that she was only sorry because
she was saying killing Bucky but now
there isn't anyone around to see her
yodu reminds her that when she died the
first time she promised her herself to
live more selfishly if given a second
lace on on life and tells her that now
she has to kill Yoko if she wants to
continue on living as mitaka falls into
a trip she contemplates on if she should
actually go through with it but ends up
ultimately ignoring yodu and decides to
save her new friend picking up Yuko she
runs from the bat devil once again as he
continues chasing after her demolishing
the building and his path for a moment
it looks as though A girl may be able to
escape however as per usual klutzy self
she accidentally trips on a loose tile
and falls to the ground face first
laying there on the floor now she
recalls how at every single critical
moment in her life she always trips and
freaking Falls her friend's birthday a
trackmate and of course I remember that
one time Genji fought the typhoon devil
well that just happened to be situated
exactly where her house was she
remembers how windy was chaos and
destruction everywhere she just like
every other top tier character in the
series stopped to help an injured cat
while she was still running from the
typhoon devil but because she did so she
tripped and fell the only reason she's
even here today is because mother pulled
it back to her feet before sadly being
taken out by the typhoon of debris
behind her then recalling the
conversation she had with Yuko the day
before ASA thinks about how initially
she only thought Yoko was trying to save
her and wasn't asking to be rescued Yuko
though who literally couldn't have cared
like less about how she felt it's just a
goddamn amazing person explained that it
doesn't matter if her actions turn out
to be a mistake as long as her heart is
in the right place that makes her happy
taking these words to her heart herself
mitaka realizes that she wants to live
like that too yeah it may have been her
fault that her mother died but she
reaffirms to herself her motivation to
help people wasn't wrong either ASA
still sprinting forward promises herself
that she will save you code but as per
usual Kuro tatsuki Fujimoto is built of
a completely different material and he
had something else planned instead the
bat devil easily catches and swallows
the two of him whole seemingly ending
her short but amazing part in the series
until of course our boy like the
freaking hero he is comes out of nowhere
already completely transformed into his
chainsaw form and fighting another
massive devil he instantly crashes
through the building squishing the bed
devil killing it a second time and
sending Yoko and ASA directly shooting
back out of the mouth that just
swallowed them continuing on his
complete bait down chainsaw man drags
the large cockroach devil through City
Block as the two of them go from
building to building and their intense
fight the Cockroach devil manages to
quickly grab dingy and throws him into
another apartment building then the
yolked up dude manages to follow up with
one of those one punch Man level of
barrages pummelyn dingy even further
into the housing unit instantly shooting
out from the rubble though dingy quickly
cuts the devil causing him to retreat
back and heal up while out of dinji's
distance the devil manages to think that
he got the upper hand and forces Mr
chainsaw man to make one of those crazy
Life Choices you usually do on a
computer others say the car full of old
woman or a young aspiring college
student dingy being dingy though
ultimately makes his own decision and
decides to aim for the devil's head
instead he shoots forward while cutting
off each of its arms before effortlessly
splitting its head in half while also
neglecting to save either of his two
choices who fall to the ground and die
because our boy saves something else
even more precious somehow throughout
this insane battle he noticed a cat that
was about to fall was able to save it
just in time after obliterating the
Cockroach The Evil later that day and in
one of those random street shops that
sell TVs and news broadcast details the
events of the battle to all of the
dedicated chainsaw man fans it's
explained that in yet another Act of
heroism chainsaw man has saved a cat
from the Cockroach devil
so it officially brings us to the very
end of what is you know the introduction
Arc to part two of change swimming
obviously there isn't kind of an
introduction Arc here as this obviously
leaves off on a cliffhanger and there's
some stuff currently going on in the
story that's almost finished that I will
turn into another Arc and release
hopefully in the up and coming weeks
which technically is the entire first
Arc of part two but I really wanted to
you know re-release the entire chainsaw
man story that just got age restricted
on my channel and I wanted to just add a
bit more in there as well in general I
didn't want to just re-release it with
blue and everything as I find it's just
kind of a a little bit boring I wanted
to add you know an entire new part of
this story and if I could you know and
get people introduced to you know like
part two of the manga if they want to
start reading it weekly then they can
you know go ahead and do that because
it's absolutely amazing at the moment
you know I'm loving this stuff with Asa
and currently dingy and how they're
fighting and how the fact that dingy
might end up actually dying and be
turned into a whip and could be
extremely interesting obviously enough
of me rambling on about things if you
guys have enjoyed this video then make
sure you hit that like button and also
be sure to subscribe if you are new
around here and and if you want to see
these videos just slightly earlier like
a few hours earlier or a day earlier it
just depends how quickly I'm like able
to eat at them then make sure you go and
check out my patreon which I will leave
down in the description below but anyway
enough of that for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and I
will see you all enable bye